[Music]
i was 17
i read a quote that went something like
if you live each day as if it was your
last
someday you'll most certainly be right
it made an impression on me and since
then for the past 33 years
i've looked in the mirror every morning
and asked myself if today were the last
day of my life
would i want to do what i am about to do
today
and whenever the answer has been no for
too many days in a row
i know i need to change something
remembering that i'll be dead soon
is the most important tool i've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life
because almost everything all external
expectations
all pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure
these things just fall away in the face
of death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die
is the best way i know to avoid the trap
of thinking
you have something to lose you are
already naked
there is no reason not to follow your
heart
no one wants to die even people who want
to go to heaven
don't want to die to get there and yet
death is the destination we all share no
one has ever escaped it
and that is as it should be because
death
is very likely the single best invention
of life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new
right now the new is you but someday not
too long from now
you will gradually become the old and be
cleared away
sorry to be so dramatic but it's quite
true
your time is limited so don't waste it
living someone
else's life don't be trapped by dogma
which is living with the results of
other people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drown out your own inner voice
and most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition
they somehow already know what you truly
want to become
everything else is secondary
sometime life sometimes life's going to
hit you in the head with a brick
don't lose faith i'm convinced that the
only thing that kept me going
was that i loved what i did you've got
to find what you love
and that is as true for work as it is
for your lovers
your work is going to fill a large part
of your life and the only way to be
truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great work
and the only way to do great work is to
love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't
settle as with all matters of the heart
you'll know when you find it
and like any great relationship it just
gets better and better
as the years roll on so keep looking
don't settle
you